now it's thursday and time for puppy pig
skin picks
sponsored by subaru of las vegas john
with the animal foundation always good
to see you
you too who's this handsome young man
this is edward he's about a year old
come here edward 25 pounds turn around
show everybody how cute you are real
handsome dog he is so
pretty and he's not only he's not really
sweet
hi he's just got amazing eyes
aren't they beautiful they're like a
crystal blue color oh my goodness
open your eyes you're so pretty he's got
a pink nose and how old is he
about a year a year so he's a stray you
don't know much about him we don't
well our crew has really enjoyed him
you've got some special things coming up
we do now through november 1st we have
our adult dogs over 30 pounds we're
waiving adoption fees for them so that's
a nice promotion oh absolutely and what
else
um best in show is coming up again um
november 15th
it's our biggest fundraiser of the year
so you can go online it's virtual this
year
so with a 20 donation you can watch it
online okay and this is the first year
actually where
we're letting the public help decide the
winner of the show all right well we're
going to let you do the picks
uh the pick this week between denver and
the chargers
go for it edward let's pick one go
make your pick it's gonna be a broncos
win
according to edwards and i'm telling you
the percentages are pretty good with our
dog so far
well if you'd like to adopt edward call
the animal foundation to make an
appointment
and that number is right there on your
screen 702-955-5901 and i tell you guys
his his hair was so soft he was so
sweet he looked like a very sweet dog